today on the matt well show with the
what is a woman question going
mainstream hopefully coinciding with the
announcement of my upcoming what is a
woman documentary we should probably try
to figure out why exactly this question
is so confusing to people to that end
there are a couple points that i think
are often overlooked we'll talk about
that also joe biden has more good news
food shortages are on the horizon and
north korea releases an unintentionally
hilarious hype video for their new
missile that they just launched plus a
heterosexual journalist comes out as
queer though he's still heterosexual how
does that work and we debate the
question is it racist to tip in our
daily cancellation a relationship guru
gives some life hacks for how to date
quote unquote 15 men in 21 days as she
did i think i know the answer though
it's probably not the one that she would
give talk about all that and more today
on the matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i've been talking to you a lot lately
about inflation we've all been talking
about inflation is at seven percent like
it is now that paper money in your
wallet is losing value fast and russia's
full-scale invasion of ukraine is now
worse in the markets slow decline today
an ounce of gold is worth nineteen
hundred dollars it was worth about three
hundred dollars an ounce and two in uh 2
000
so that tells you where the stability is
i've been telling you for a while that
you can buy gold from birch gold it's
your hedge against inflation did you
know that there's another way to hedge
against inflation also though that's buy
silver from birch gold silver is also
considered real money and historically
speaking it's extremely undervalued
right now it's an industrial metal
that's in high demand for everything
from electronic cars to solar panels
demand is only going to rise and some
analysts suggest that there is an
unusual dislocation in price that may
present very real opportunities for
silver to rally over uh the next two
years regardless
silver like gold is never going to zero
the american dollar it's currently going
into the toilet while precious metals
are rising in value thanks to the fed
call birch gold they're the only company
i trust don't wait start diversifying
text walsh to 98 98.98 to get a free
info kit on buying gold or silver in a
tax sheltered account there is no
obligation to get this info text walsh
to 98 98.98 to get your free info kit
now yesterday we announced my upcoming
documentary what is a woman we didn't
expect as we were making the film that a
supreme court nominee would do so much
to help promote it right before the
release
in fact there were many things that
happened around this film and while
making it that we didn't quite expect
the short teaser that we released
yesterday shows a little bit of what we
did expect which is that lots of people
are unable to answer the titular
question
and then also that politicians in this
case congressman mark takano of
california uh would be very upset when
when we asked it
but there's much more to the film
much much more uh some of which you'll
see when we drop the full trailer soon
and then of course nothing will be able
to beat the experience of watching the
actual film itself when it comes out in
may if you've been hesitating on getting
a dw membership up until this point i
think i would tell you that now is the
time
because you're going to want to see this
film people will be talking about it we
did some things in this movie that
nobody's ever done before and that's not
an exaggeration and i can't say a lot
but also say that we we deployed some
methods
in order to secure some of these
interviews that have been used by other
films
plenty of times but never by anybody on
the right so you have to see it for
yourself you can go to what is a
woman.com for uh more information
when i got home from work last night
speaking of the film i i
found out that my wife had showed the
teaser to my kids uh you know they they
aren't gonna be able to watch the movie
when it comes out it's not gonna be
appropriate for them
and the full trailer and most other
clips that come out of this thing will
also probably not be appropriate for
them so this is a one piece that they
could watch and in fairness you know
they've wanted to know why i've been
traveling and i've been gone so much
over the past year i went to africa like
they don't really know why this is
happening
um and now they know sort of but are
even more confounded than they were
before probably my daughter especially
thought it was
absolutely hysterical that a bunch of
grown-ups couldn't explain what a woman
is
you know she asked me what was wrong
with all those people and i said that
lots of people in the world today are
very confused and it's very sad
and she said so so they really don't
even know what a woman is and i said no
they don't or at least they say they
don't do you know
and she quickly answered that a woman
has girl parts and she makes babies
it's about the shortest simplest and
most correct answer i've heard i
literally traveled the globe for a year
talked to doctors and scientists and
psychiatrists and so many other
credentialed so-called experts and then
finally got the right answer when i came
home
and asked my eight-year-old daughter
something quite profound about that yet
also extremely sad and terrifying
but as to the what is a woman question
as it goes mainstream finally as it
becomes inescapable even for those who
want nothing more than to escape it
i think there are a few crucial points
to be made which have so far perhaps
gotten lost in the shuffle
and these all revolve
around a different question and that is
why are we going through this
civilization-wide identity crisis why
have we tried to turn physical identity
into a complicated subject
why do we treat it as ambiguous as
abstract
ephemeral
i think there are two there are lots of
reasons but there are two big reasons
that we should
think about focus on
one you know i've said many times that
there is a vast chasm a canyon
separating the two ideological sides in
this country an expanse that cannot be
bridged
because people on either side of it have
diametrically opposed views about the
most basic elements of reality such as
you know
is there such a thing as a woman what is
a woman like you can't there's no
compromised position between those two
between those two sides and that's all
true
but that picture of a society that is
kind of cut in half
with this huge
dark pit between them that nobody can
bridge that picture's pretty bleak
it's actually though a bit too neat too
tidy
it's actually more optimistic
than what is the truth
it's a fine way of thinking about our
cultural situation generally kind of
from a bird's-eye view
but when you look closer you see that
while there is a chasm separating the
two sides there are also a bunch of
smaller chasms separating each
individual
or at least each individual on one of
those sides
this is the relativist project the
relativist tries
to lay claim
to his own reality his own universe
there's no shared universe there's no
common reality at all each individual's
identity is determined by the individual
nothing external has any say there are
no determinative factors on the outside
each person is a self-creating being
which of course is a paradox
you can't create yourself because in
order to create anything you first have
to be a self
just as you can't determine your own
identity because in order to determine
anything you first must have an identity
your identity comes from your identity
comes first
you can determine quite a lot in life
you can make many choices
but you're doing all of those things
you're acting in the world as a self
whose basic biological identity was
decided by someone or something other
than yourself
yourself cannot determine
who yourself is at such a basic level
because there has to be a self-first
that can do any determining at all
that's the reality but the left-wing
gender ideologue is rejected and so
the left-wing gender idea ideologue is
stuck in this kind of paradoxical
self-perpetuating train of circular
logic where statements like a woman as
anybody who identifies as a woman
seem to make sense but they only seem to
make sense to the gender ideologue
because he is you know he is a stuck in
a sort of circular world
where everything is running in a circle
and so
statements of circular logic he just
doesn't see it
for the nonsense that it is
second thing part of the reason that
people in our culture seek to reject
their natural identity
and this is really important and i don't
think it's not talked about nearly
enough
part of why you know they want to see
identity as fluid and arbitrary
superficial
is because they seek to escape the
duties and responsibilities that attend
your natural identity
so this is how you bridge the gap
between the left-wing war on gender
roles and their current obsession with
gender fluidity at first glance it seems
contradictory and it is because for
years they said that there are no gender
roles and there's no you know so there's
nothing wrong with a boy dressing in
pink and wearing a skirt like a boy can
do whatever he wants
there's nothing about his bulliness that
should compel him to act in any kind of
way that's what they said for years
and now they say that a boy who dresses
in pink and wears a skirt actually is a
girl
so that would seem to be a complete
reversal
wouldn't it and it is in a way but
the one thing that ties all of this
together is the rejection of natural
roles natural responsibilities
we cannot say that a man
has any particular duty as a man
if the word man doesn't mean anything
same for woman
you know one thing i found
during my travels and there's much more
to be said about this
a whole separate documentary on just
this alone could be made and should be
made
um and maybe i will be the one to make
it if no one else does but one thing i
found is that whenever i encountered
somebody with a strong sense of
responsibility
i was also encountering somebody with a
strong sense of identity
every single person i talked to
who knew exactly who they were
and there weren't a lot of those people
but the ones that i did find
they also knew exactly what they were
supposed to be doing
people who know and accept what they are
and who they are
and what they're supposed to do they're
never confused about who they are
the problem is that there are so few
people in that category in the west
anymore which is partly why we went all
the way into you know africa to the
african wilderness
and when we got down there we found
a small society's tribal society
totally organized
around the concept of responsibility
it's responsibility your duties your
roles bleeds into
every aspect of your life everything
that you do
everybody has a role and they know what
it is and so they don't question who
they are in fact if you ask them who
they are as i did
the first thing they'll tell you is what
they do what their duties are
that's how closely the two things are
intertwined
they don't even see any distinction
between it a man is what a man does
now they also understand the biological
parts of it a man has a penis and all
that but if you ask him what a if you
ask someone in one of those societies
what a man is i can tell you this now
from experience
um
the first thing they're going to tell
you about is what the man is supposed to
do they're not going to tell you oh that
he's a male and he has a penis the
reason they won't tell you that is
because they they think well that's just
so obvious why would i say that of
course everybody knows that
they assume i meant like on a sort of a
deeper level
a man is what a man does
now in the west
we we forgot what a man is supposed to
do
and then it didn't take long before we
also forgot who he is
and that
is no coincidence
as you'll see when the film comes out
what is women.com let's get now to our
five headlines
[Music]
have you ever wanted to send your uncle
a birthday greeting from one of his
favorite conservative celebrities or
have your favorite freedom-loving
comedian roast that one liberal cousin
nobody likes in the family well there's
only one place to make that reality and
it's with the new app called shout out
the most popular personalities on the
right are ready to make someone's day
with a personalized video download shout
out now on the app store and google play
to get 20 off your first customized
shout out video from the likes of steven
crowder the hodge twins jp sears jason
whitlock alex jones and many more of
your favorite conservative celebrities
download the shout out app today
i just got this text from my sister i
just think this is great and it's a new
kind of uh i don't know this is this is
a monetizable thing that we can
explore here i'd never thought about
this before
but uh she just texted me this i mean
she texts me right before i went on air
so i like i if you do that i think
everyone in my life should know you text
me before before air time i have the
right to just read your text publicly so
um she said i have to tell you the
funniest thing my co-worker is a big fan
of yours she was just telling me that
she has a problem at her house with a
fox attacking her chickens and she's
been trying to deter it she heard that
human voices are a deterrent so she set
up an ipod near her chicken coop and has
your podcast running on a loop 24 7 very
loudly and it worked
your voice is apparently a successful
fox deterrent
and as a bonus she's evangelizing her
liberal neighbor so
that is uh
and we're racking up those downloads as
well i kind of i kind of like this if
you've got any problems with with
yeah i think in general you don't have a
chicken coop
you've got wild animals
out there you've got maybe raccoons
getting into your garbage
just set up the podcast have it running
on a loop
and uh
and then yeah that is also the bonus is
that you're you're gonna be driving your
neighbors completely insane
i'll take that as a compliment that my
voice scares away wild animals
um
all right
let's uh
let's start with this joe biden
yesterday uh he's just a guy full of
good news you can remember before
you know we had the first day of spring
this uh this
this week
and so winter's officially over
and we remember we go back to whatever
whatever it was november december joe
biden promised us a winter of death and
sickness and despair
and didn't seem to be that for me i mean
you know it seems like um
the winter wasn't too bad but he
promised it would be a winter of death
and uh winter of death didn't exactly
work out
but now
maybe we'll have a spring of death
because he says that uh food shortages
are on the horizon listen
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries in our country as
well
and uh because both uh russia and
ukraine
have been the bread basket of europe in
terms of wheat for example just give one
example
but we had a long discussion uh in the
g7
with uh um
the uh
with both uh the united states which has
a significant the third largest producer
of wheat in the world
as well as canada which is also a major
major producer and we both talked about
how we could increase and disseminate
more rapidly
food shortages in addition to that we
talked about
urging all the european countries and
everyone else to
end trade
restrictions on
on sending uh
limitations on sending food abroad
and so we are in the process of working
out with our european friends
what it would be what it would take to
help alleviate the concerns relative to
food shortages we also talked about a
significant major u.s investment among
others in terms of providing for
the need for
humanitarian assistance including food
as we move forward
so what exactly happened to build back
better i think we've moved on from that
i guess no more no more building back
better
now we have winters of death
winter of death going into a spring of
despair
food shortages now he says food
shortages are coming
last i checked they've already kind of
been here
and so that's that's part of what is is
happening here why joe biden's going
around talking about food shortages
um
promising that things are going to get
so much worse and we've heard a lot i've
never heard i i can't remember ever
hearing
this much
pessimism from a politician who's in
charge of things now it's one thing when
you're
running against an incumbent
and then you're pessimistic about the
way things are going right now and you
say well elect me and things will be
better
but for the guy who's actually in charge
who's this pessimistic about by the way
things are heading
um
part of the reason for that of course is
now he's trying to pin everything on on
putin
and so you say oh food shortages are
coming because of you know the war in
russia and putin and he's doing all this
well as i said last i checked
that was already a problem i mean joe
biden i think fairly was getting labeled
bare shelves biden
before the war in ukraine
you know you could go uh on
social media and find the pictures of
bear shells grocery stores going back
months before any of this happened
so this is uh this has been a great
opportunity for biden to take all of
these things that were already happening
gas prices inflation food shortages
uh supply chain issues all that stuff
all that was already happening was
already trending in this direction and
take it all and just put it in the lap
of putin
that's why that's why i you know by
demonstration very grateful in fact
what's happening in ukraine right now
because it gives them an opportunity to
blame all of their own failures on putin
all these things are already happening
now is
putin's invasion of ukraine is that
helping any of these issues is it
helping gas prices no
is it contributing to some of the
problems sure
but none of these things began a few
weeks ago when putin invaded ukraine
we were already headed in that direction
and um
and now he wants of course pin it all in
putin
you also get the sense
here's the most disturbing thing for me
every time i i
see joe biden and i listen to him and
he's talking about these problems
um
you get the sense well first of all of
course that he's just confused and he
doesn't know exactly what's going on
because he does have dementia and we
have a president with dementia
um that's what happens when you
decide that an 80 year old needs to be
president
but you also get the sense that he
doesn't
he doesn't seem to care that much
about any of these problems there's no
real there's no real sense of urgency at
all from this guy
that's why when all hell's breaking
loose he'll just go off to delaware and
you know take a five-day weekend
that's why he's still he's still going
to bed at 7 30
um
even the midst of
crisis after crisis
some of that is
again the fact that he is physically
mentally collapsing
but it's also i think a lack of urgency
a lack of concern
and that goes back to his own moral
failings but also that also could be
traced back to his age
you know that i i hate to always have to
tie everything back to this and harp on
this point but it's an important point
and i think we need to keep it front of
mind here
that yeah even if joe even if this was
if joe biden was 20 years younger we'd
still be having a lot of the same
problems
because he still he still would be
incompetent
but um
this is only making all those problems
even worse
the fact that he's so old
and i think it contributes to a lack of
urgency and a lack of concern because uh
well frankly
he's not gonna be around
for very long because he's old
so i don't think he's sitting around
really worried about long-term
solutions
this is not going to be his problem for
very long
yet another reason why we need younger
people in office and not just in the
white house i mean in office running the
country
we need younger
people so that they're more physically
and mentally equipped but also so that
they have a stake in the future so
they're going to be around
to deal with the consequences of
whatever decisions they make
and their kids are gonna be around and
they're going to be around also to see
their kids dealing with those
consequences
it always makes me nervous even more
nervous when i when i consider the fact
that so many of the people at the
highest levels of government making the
most important decisions
are not going to be around to see the
consequences of any of these decisions
i think that should make us all very
nervous
you know you have a president who's in
his you know 40s 50s even 60s like he's
got
several decades left probably on earth
you never know for sure no one knows
when they're when they're leaving but um
these are people who have decades left
and they're going to be around
um
and
that's it's all inevitable the
consequence of
going into a nursing home and finding
the most geriatric people and saying hey
you want to run the country
all right moving from the united states
over to north korea i just got to play
this for you because it's um
on one hand you can't help but laugh
because how else because
how else can you respond to something
like this but then also you consider
this guy's a ruthless dictator and he
runs concentration camps and kills
thousands of his own people um so that
takes away from some of the
the uh
the humor some of the comedic effect of
this kind of thing but but either way so
this is apparently from
this is a north korean state media they
put out this propaganda piece
and this is uh
kim jong-un unveiling
a new missile that they just launched
and they kind of put together a little
little hype video
and let's uh let's check this out let's
see
we say kim coming out of there he's got
his generals there oh he's pointing
those are the people he wants executed
he's pointing to them execute that
person
execute him too he's gone
now those generals
this is the fifth take in the first four
[Music]
in the video were all executed
and there's the missile now he's
checking his watch
i don't know why they're getting
and all these generals they know
[Music]
that's the most intense i've ever seen
the most intense scene of people
checking watches i've ever seen
[Music]
oh is that it they don't even launch the
mission missile
so that was just them bringing the
missile out of the garage
i guess there's probably a sequel where
they actually launch the thing but we
won't bother watching that
you know they're trying i mean they've
got um
they're doing what they can over there
i guess to uh
at least keep their their dictator
entertained all right let's go to this
one the wire says actress gabrielle
union is known for her stance on trans
issues involving children
she her husband formed freshman
basketball player dwyane wade have a
teenager who identifies as trans
this has inspired you to become an
outspoken advocate for lgbt issues
especially as they relate to kids
the actress recently expressed her
thoughts during an interview with
buzzfeed
and she said it's important for us to
live and love out loud we didn't exactly
understand why supporting ziya's trans
identity so that's zaya is what they're
calling her kid
we don't understand exactly why
supporting zionist trans identity was a
thing because it's like we love all our
kids out loud um
their 14 year old child came out
as trans in 2019
well no he and i'm not even sure ziya is
this a a male or i'm not even sure so
i'd like to use the appropriate
pronouns here but i'm not even sure what
they are
oh it's a boy okay all right so this is
this is actually a boy their 14 year old
child zaya came out as trans of 2019. um
so he would have been
you know he would have been 11 10 11
around there when when uh when when he
came out so he
he didn't actually
come out that's that's not what happened
i mean you can't come out and identify
as something that you don't understand
you don't understand what you're saying
this was this is an identity that was
imposed on him i'm not saying entirely
by his parents
because it's probably not entirely by
the parents
it's by friends society the school
system
all of these various institutions but
the parents were were quite eager and
anxious to go along with it
so then so they could then take
little xayah and parade him all around
in media and everything and show him off
and because here's the thing
um
xayah quote unquote came out as trans in
2019 and 2019 is when we first heard
about xayah becoming a girl quote
unquote
so they it's not like they waited
dwayne wade and gabrielle union they
didn't they didn't wait like as soon as
that happened they had him in front of
cameras boom
so if there was ever any doubt about the
motivations here that should put those
doubts to rest
um
if your child is supposedly
coming out as trans
and the very next thing you do
is alert the media
and get them out on the red carpet in uh
in dresses and so on and do interviews
and everything then it's very clear this
is not about the kid it's about you
your kid is a trophy that you are
showing off
to display how woke you are
um
union continues as our children show up
it's our job to believe them when they
tell us who they are and not impose our
dreams hopes fears and desires on them
it's our job to be loving compassionate
protective guides for our children but
their lives are their lives and we have
to respect that we do not believe in any
kind of shaming for existing that is
bizarre cruel and harmful
so yeah we're going to post our family
we're going to live out loud we're going
to love out loud and we're going to
speak out loud and lead and however each
situation calls for us to be leaders
when things are not where they should be
uh
all right
a couple of things here
first of all even putting aside um the
issue of of trans and the fact that
you're imposing this
what sadly and tragically will probably
be a lifelong identity crisis on your
child putting that to the side for a
second it is certainly not your um 11
year old
child's job to be a leader
on anything on any issue whatsoever okay
i don't care what the issue is
i don't care if it's even a worthwhile
issue
um your lev your 11 year old child's job
is is right now just to be a child
and to learn and be educated
to uh have some moral formation which is
supposed to be your job as a parent
you're obviously doing a terrible job of
that
you've gone more the direction of moral
deformation and moral formation
but on your job your child's not
supposed to be living out loud as you
say which what you mean is when you say
live out loud what you mean is on
display for the world to see
love out loud that again is on display
so oh we're loving our children out loud
translation we are our supposed love for
our children is a performance
and we're doing this on a stage for the
world to see
and as to the rest of it oh it's she
says that
it's our our children tell us who they
are and it's our job to listen i mean
this is
uh in fact i i know someone who wrote a
whole book about that concept called
johnny the walrus which you can also get
at johnnywalrus.com
because that is the that's the
consequence that's how absurd it is
your job is to listen to your child when
he tells you who he is
no not at all because your child has no
idea who he is
children are not born into the world
with knowledge about almost anything
you have to teach them
okay you're
just as you're it's not your child's job
to lead in society it's not your child's
job to be a an activist
it's especially not your child's job to
lead your family
now you don't you don't follow his lead
and say well he'll tell us who he is and
what he wants to do and we'll we're just
going to follow behind him
applauding him all the way
well then you're going to be following
and applauding as your child goes right
off of a cliff
only the thing is you're not going to
jump off the cliff with them
you're going to stand at the edge and
watch him fall and just applaud there
you go looks fun
no you're supposed to say to the to the
kid even and sometimes they won't they
won't like this because kids can be
obstinate and stubborn and they want to
get their way uh so sometimes you have
to be forceful about it but you you you
stop your kid and say no no let me get
in front you come in behind me i'll show
you where we're going because you don't
know and that's what you need me to do
for you
because that over there is a cliff and
you're a kid and you're stupid and
you're going to think that you're just
going to walk right over and be fine but
i know better because i'm an adult so
i'm going to
guide you on this path over here that's
what you're supposed to be doing
um i also wanted to mention this this is
kind of interesting terrell jermaine
starr is a
i guess a
a journalist he's got a blue check on
twitter so we know he's an important
person
and he uh tweeted this he says
i've just started identifying as queer
over the last four months
does that make me the new queer but an
old black
and then he continues because you're
wondering well he just he just started
he just started identifying as queer
this is not the same thing as i'm coming
out as gay i've been gay my whole life
and i haven't told anybody and uh and
now i'm i'm
living out loud as gabriel union would
say
no i just started identifying as queer
okay what does that mean he continues
i think most men especially black men
like me
who come out later in life it's because
we don't really know it ourselves also
i'm attracted to a wide range of women
but not men at all so i don't so i
didn't know how to id myself even though
i haven't felt straight in years lol
for me embracing being queer was as much
as intellectual journey as it was other
areas just the way i think of structural
oppression comes from not feeling
heteronormative in my thinking about
things
okay so
he's only attracted to women he makes
very clear about that
but he's attracted to a wide range of
of women
i don't know exactly what that means
uh a wide range of babies attracted to
larger women okay that's that's fine
some guys are
they're still women though
um and but in spite of that he hasn't so
you're attracted to women and only women
you're a man but you don't feel straight
what does that mean does it mean that
you you also attracted to men no no
you're only attracted to women
i just don't feel straight
i you know i have feeling i'm a straight
person
and i have feelings and i'm assuming
that the feelings i'm having right now
are not the feelings that other straight
people have even though i only like
women
of course none of this makes any sense
whatsoever
but it does show a couple of things uh
one is how
you know
this
this lgbt indoctrination that's going on
we we focus a lot i mean i focus a lot
on how this affects children how
children are being kind of groomed and
uh indoctrinated and that's true and
that's a big problem but it's not just
children this is happening too it's
happening to adults also
adults also are being in effect groomed
by this stuff
and indoctrinated into it
now with them it's a little bit
different because they're they are more
willful participants in their own
indoctrination um
and the reason why he's going along with
it is because you know it it's also
trendy there is a there's a
there are many social benefits of being
able to say i'm queer
and the great thing is if you're
interested in those social benefits the
word queer that like doesn't mean
anything anymore
um and so
you can claim that label for yourself
and uh and no one's allowed to question
it because it's your label
and now if you're a man you know you
could still date women but you can have
all the social credibility of uh of
being lgbt
as far as tyrell's concerned it's the
best of both worlds
all right here's another tweet this
one's from representative casey
weinstein who's a
state representative in ohio
and i thought this was this was good he
says in ohio
you need a license to fish but not to
cons not to uh concealed carry a gun
think about that you need a license to
fish
but not to have concealed carry for a
gun
think about it
well i am thinking about it and i
actually totally agree with him that
this is completely insane
um
you should not need a license to fish
that's that's the conclusion i think we
could draw from there
now
uh
i say that as someone avid fisherman
myself
i've fished in many you know five six
different states
i've never actually bothered to get a
license
but there shouldn't be the regulation
that i have to ignore i shouldn't be
forced to ignore this regulation
shouldn't be there to begin with and
since you brought up the subject i mean
just think about that for a second
that if you want to grab a fishing pole
and go to a lake or a pond
and you know throw some bait in there
you got to get a license from the
government
it's it's
you know one of the many absurdities
that you know that we
tolerate in terms of the government just
it's it's
blatantly nothing but fundraising
not not much different from the red
light cameras that they put up or
anything like that all it is is
fundraising because the other thing
about the fishing license is that if you
do go get one you go to you can go to
any sporting goods store or whatever if
you feel like getting one
even though again there's no reason to
actually do it because i
while i've never gotten a license i've
also never ever been asked to produce
one and i've never seen anyone be asked
to produce one
maybe maybe there are some lakes in the
country where this actually happens i've
never encountered it i've never seen it
but if you do go get the license i know
there's there's nothing to it they just
they'll you you pay them 50 bucks or
whatever it is depending on what kind of
license you're trying to get um you
don't have to there's no training they
don't they don't make sure that you know
how to cast or anything like that
there's no training that goes into it
it's not like a it's not like a driver's
license where they want to make sure
that you're not going to kill somebody
when you're out there driving
um nothing like that you just got to pay
them and then you they'll let you go
fish
nothing but fundraising so
inadvertently casey weinstein has
brought up a good point here
get rid of the
license to fish
also you shouldn't need a license to
carry a gun around either okay one other
quick thing i want to mention is from a
few days ago
the dws nicole hannah jones new york
times reporter and creator of the 1619
project riled up social media on monday
when she tweeted that tipping is a
legacy of slavery
what reason does she have i haven't read
this until now so i'm not sure what her
argument is maybe it's a good argument
not holding my breath she's never made a
good argument for anything but
tipping is a legacy of slavery and if
it's not optional then it shouldn't be a
tip but simply included in the bill she
wrote
he ever stopped to think why we tip
like why tipping is a practice in the
u.s and almost nowhere else
um
okay well what's the how do you connect
it to slavery that's what i'm trying to
see hannah jones 45 created the 1619
project we know about that
um
i'm just skimming through to see if she
actually gives a reason
how do you click i want to know how do
you connect these dots
and then she's okay then she's getting
criticized on twitter she responds to it
she says are y'all reading what i'm
writing or no
i said i tip i tip well i tip almost
always
but i object to the idea that i'm
obligated to tip no matter how i'm
treated nope
and you can't get more offended at me
than employers that pay less than
minimum wage so here's my question who
is the slave in this analogy
is it the the person working for tips is
the slave that's that's i figure that's
what she meant
but then reading more it sounds like
she's saying that we are turned into
slaves because we're forced you know by
social pressure to give tips to someone
who's already i don't know i'm not sure
how she
dissects that exactly
i'm not sure if i would say that tipping
has a is
is a holdover from slavery in fact i
would say that it definitely isn't i
mean quite famously um slaves didn't
earn tips they didn't earn anything at
all it's what makes you a slave
so i'm not gonna agree with that
um
but i do think and i think we've talked
about before that although i i you know
i consider myself to be a pretty good
tipper
i still tip in most situations
um
tipping has however gotten way out of
control everywhere you go now they
expect a tip
and um whether it's a tip jar or now
they get more aggressive about it and
they actually will ask you
or now that everywhere you go that you
know you have to pay on the ipad thing
and then they flip it around and there's
always a oh do you want you want to
leave a 15 tip a 25 tip
um so i think it's gotten way out of
hand i think we need to
stop for a second
and have a conversation about tipping
not about whether it has any connection
to slavery but just what is the point of
the tip
and which which industry should have
this and not
i can understand in the food industry
you know a waiter first of all is not
getting paid a lot but also
you know your experience at the
restaurant is going to be so much
determined by how good your waiter is
and so i understand the tip
and it's also a way of rewarding really
good service penalizing bad service i
understand it that way
but if all you're doing is just pouring
a cup of coffee for me and handing it to
me
like i could cut you out of that
completely
just give me the cup and i'll pour it
myself
so i understand tipping for that that's
a conversation maybe we'll have another
time let's get out of the comment
sections
[Music]
[Music]
all right we'll take a look at one video
comment which is clip eight
hey matt uh i don't know if i'm allowed
to be featured in the video comments
twice
that weird guy that made those videos
that annoyed you did but i think it
might only be allowed if mckenna wants
to annoy you anyways um
i just watched candace
i watched the water test
and she took a sip
from what said aquafina before the signs
were flipped down
and said oh this is desani and then when
she picked up the sign it said to sani
but that's where aquafina was
candace is the cheater
sweet baby gang for life yeah that
many nefarious things went on
surrounding that
that water test uh
i think we will never
know
the full truth we'll never know
everything that happened
um
historians will be debating this
for decades and centuries to come
all
and and you're right i mean what you
pointed out there are it's it's if you
if you watch
it's quite disturbing i've had many
people reach out to me and because first
of all they want to know am i okay
how am i doing and i appreciate that
and the answer is i'm doing all right
but i'm still i'm still recovering in a
lot of ways from what happened
but you can notice some interesting
things with the way the water test was
was edited and some
some
cups are mysteriously moving around and
signs are moving around no one knows
what's happening
um
it would take too long to sort all out
but but all you need to know is that of
course i did
i did win
uh let's see frankie price says if your
entire ideology can be destroyed by one
question it was never strong to begin
with well that's an understatement
that's exactly the point that's why we
made the film
what is woman.com
um mark says it was very good of uh k
bay g k b j k b j there we go to
coordinate with your movie release yeah
it is it really did i mean you can't
plan it any better than this
um and it is and i i do appreciate that
at least from her
lena says i can't wait for the film to
come out i i hope you have a good
contingency plan in case some social
media platforms kick you out well
there's no real contingency plan i mean
that's just
right now anyway that's the unfortunate
reality
is that um the most powerful social
media platforms are the ones that are
run by the left and
if they if they kick you off which
i think there's a pretty good chance
that will happen to me i'm surprised it
hasn't happened yet to me
um it's inevitable that eventually that
will happen to me just like it will
happen to any conservative who's
outspoken and has a platform i think
with this movie coming out like i said
yesterday i don't i don't see how all of
my social media
platforms
survive the release of the movie not
that they have any good reason to kick
me off because of the movie but doesn't
mean they won't do it uh but in terms of
a contingency plan what do you do
instead i mean just the reality is
they kick you off and it doesn't mean
that you're erased from existence but
that will succeed in cutting you off
from
a certain portion of an audience
and there really isn't any
replacement right now
i think we should work on building some
you know building some social media
platforms
um
where you can actually say things like
men have penises
without being kicked off we like that
should exist and we should work on that
and i know that there are some platforms
that are out there where um you can say
these sorts of forbidden things without
being without being uh canceled
but none of them
have anywhere close to the power of uh
twitter or facebook or any of that
we're far away from anything that could
be considered a real alternative
a real whatever you want to call it free
speech alternative conservative
alternative um to twitter and facebook
that doesn't really exist yet
and part of the reason for that is that
most of the
uh the wannabe alternatives that have
come along
you know they
they are focused too much on just being
the conservative version of twitter
rather than innovating something new and
giving people a real reason to leave and
use their platform
and we heard a lot about truth social
which is trump's platform and as far as
i know he hasn't even posted on it
himself i think he posted on himself
when they first launched it a month ago
and hasn't posted on it since um
and at a minimum he needs to be posting
on that thing all the time if he wants
any chance of that of it surviving
but the problem is you know i took a
look at it and and it's just it's just
twitter it's like exactly the same as
twitter there's no innovation going into
it and so there's just not going to be
the incentive for people to go and try
that product instead
um
trust me says now candace owens has to
apologize to matt how can she be so
slanderous to him in his cult when he is
doing such amazing work and to think
that the slander came from bottled water
that's almost as ridiculous as not being
able to say what a woman is maybe we
need a new documentary what is dasani
because you know
she obviously can't tell
well as you've heard you know i've been
working on a secret project for over a
year and it is called what is a woman
there's a lot more to be
said about this and that will be
revealed over the coming weeks uh but
what i can tell you is that this is the
most important question
of 2022 and i think though i'm biased i
think that this really is the most
important film of 2022 as well take a
look at this sneak peek
i have traveled all over the world
for the past year
asking one simple question
what is
a woman
what is a woman what is it what is it i
don't know people are laughing is that
is that a dumb question
i've been asking everybody this and
almost nobody can answer it what is a
woman what is a woman
that's a great question
[Music]
if one person could tell me what a woman
is
congressman thank you for for being here
i think this interview is over let's
turn off the cameras just wanted to know
what is a woman and you're not going to
find out
it's not a complicated question
what we're doing here is we are
questioning
the logic of the trans movement of
gender ideology we're going right to its
core um and because it's a movement
that's taken aim at women and children
if you want to join the fight head to
dailywire.com subscribe and enter code
what is a woman for 25 off your
membership uh like i said if you haven't
got a membership yet and you've been
holding off you've been thinking about
it now is the time to get it you're
going to want to see this film and we've
got a lot of other great content too
with daily wire a lot more coming up so
get your 25 off use code what is a woman
this fight is for everything it's for
truth itself what is a woman coming 20
22. now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well it's friday so we're going to go
easy on our daily cancellation i don't
mean go easy as and be nice i definitely
won't be nice
that's one promise i can make and always
keep it's my undying pledge but uh i
mean you know have a sort of an easy
subject there's a headline from the new
york post which cries out for
cancellation i think um and i need to do
very little except just sort of point in
its direction the headline how i hacked
tinder and dated 15 men in 21 days
now reading along it says
with the tinder swindler a blockbuster
success on netflix many women are wary
of matching with a man online but one
australian woman says tinder is the
perfect place to meet mr wright and is
revealing the simple hacks she uses to
maximize chances of success on the app
i'm going to stop right here there's
almost no reason to read any more we
have all we need i guess but let me just
say at the outset
first of all that i'm already canceling
this woman and whoever wrote this
article
simply for the way they're using the
word hack
because somewhere along the line this
concept of life hacks came into
existence and now the internet is
pockmarked with 14 billion different
articles guides videos different you
know things giving advice on how to hack
various aspects of life we used to just
call this advice or tips
now it's a hack because hack sounds more
secretive and clever and edgy like it's
some sort of forbidden knowledge but
then the advice the hack is often
something incredibly basic that
everybody already knew like um
here's a life hack if you don't want to
trip while you're walking down the steps
tie your shoes or else it goes the other
way and the hack actually offers a more
complicated and inefficient way of
performing some routine task so it'll be
something like life hack
make sure you don't lose your car keys
by having them surgically attached to
your hand
so the whole
life hacking trend is stupid and it is
what i'm saying and
we could cancel just that but that's not
the primary point today in this
particular case
the life hack is a method discovered by
an australian woman for how to quote
unquote date
i think we know what she means which he
says date
15 men in less than a month now i can
already tell you how to achieve this
goal
if for some reason you want to
i'll give you the step-by-step process
for dating 15 minutes 21 days
one
be a woman
two have no moral standards
that's it those are all the steps
in fact you could probably um hack this
hack and remove the first step entirely
which you really have to seeing as how
women don't exist but really if you're
if you're any sort of person looking to
date any other sort of person
you can find an essentially unlimited
supply if you have no sorts of standards
whatsoever if you're a warm body looking
for other warm bodies
and you are unburdened by any moral
sensibilities and have no aesthetic
requirements either
the internet will provide you with all
the fodder you need
and you don't even need to be a warm
body actually pete davidson is basically
dead and look how well he's done on the
dating scene this is the world we live
in now
but then again you know i'm a married
man
i've never used tinder what do i know so
let's go back to the article and see
what tips and tricks this woman offers
i'm guessing she offers a lot of tricks
offers them turns them etc here's what
it says
helen chick who hails from sydney says
dating is simply a numbers game and
boasts that she had tinder dates with 15
different men during a recent work trip
a three-week trip to new york city the
serial dater who has penned the book sex
swipes and other stories divulged how
she managed to meet so many men in such
a short period of time chick declared
that everything comes down to time and
urge tinder users not to procrastinate
while on the app she said it's important
to get small talk out of the way quickly
so that you can meet up in person as
soon as possible quote change your
location prior to arriving in the city
so you're basically matching people in
the city you're not actually physically
in but you can do all the tedious small
talk banter vibe checks et cetera before
you arrive she advised for those who are
hoping to date locally chick further
divulged her hack for cutting down on
small talk the savvy swiper said she
divides conversations into two
categories need to know and nice to know
the latter consists of light-hearted
trivial topics while the former is
focused on determining a person's morals
goals and values chick claims
conversations should be focused on the
need to know category so as to quickly
figure out whether two people are
compatible prior to putting energy into
a date
by the way um
she wants to know about your morals and
values specifically to ensure that you
like her don't have any
and and that's really her life hack she
dedicated a whole book to it
her advice um don't bother talking or
getting to know
someone
just cut right to the chase get in bed
with them and move to the next one
so in other words it's exactly the
two-step
two-step process i mentioned at the
start be a woman
have no soul
in a pinch the first step can even be
skipped
now there's one other bit at the very
end that you'll find totally shocking it
says chick is twice divorced and she
says that that fact is a part of the
need to know category she always shares
that personal information before an
in-person meetup
twice divorced who could have possibly
predicted
twice divorced and writing a
relationship handbook
that's like me writing a book on fashion
tips
and that would be a short book also
chapter one where plaid the end
now if i may be so bold as to disagree
with the um
multiply divorced relationship guru who
collects venereal diseases like their
souvenirs
i would say that the correct approach to
dating is precisely the opposite of what
she recommends
now sure this does somewhat depend on
your goals if you're if you're an empty
miserable lonely nihilist who has
despaired of love and trust and meaning
and now wishes only to use other human
bodies like glorified masturbatory
devices
screwing the days away until you die
alone and cold with no one to mourn you
and no legacy to leave behind then
helen's method is the way to go no doubt
but if you actually want some kind of
joy and you care about things like human
dignity um your own and other people's
and if you want to have actual love and
happiness in your life and you want to
leave this world knowing that your time
was spent in a meaningful way and that
your progeny will live on even as you
move to the hereafter if that sounds
more appealing
then your best bet is to consider
the helens of this world and the way
they approach these things and do
exactly the opposite of what they do
you're not looking for raw numbers here
the people you're dating aren't bowling
pins that you want to simply lie down so
you can collect the point and win
whatever game it is you think you're
playing the goal of dating is to find
one person
a person who shares your basic values
and priorities
someone who you find physically
attractive that's important also
um someone you you feel a connection
with and then once you've found that
person
that that the game's over you one move
on with them and build a life together
in marriage this means you're not
looking to
get talking out of the way when you
first meet them so you can jump in bed
together jumping in bed with them
doesn't tell you anything about them
other than the fact that they're the
kind of person who does that so actually
tells you a lot
which means they probably aren't the
kind of person you want to marry but
then again you also would be the kind of
person who does that and means you're
the kind of person people shouldn't want
to marry so best to skip that step or
rather to hold off on it until the
proper time which comes within the bonds
of marriage and instead focus on getting
to know this individual and who they
actually are and what they believe
what sort of person they are
you don't need to know everything
you don't need a list of every quirk
every habit every last detail
you don't need to know things like uh do
they have any annoying habits they do i
can tell you that for sure
you just need to know about their moral
character can you relate to them can you
trust them
if everything lines up
you can both you know both of you can
free yourself from the clutches of the
modern dating scene which is infested
with people like helen
and move to the altar
which is supposed to be the end point of
the dating process
and you can live then maybe not happily
ever after there will still be ups and
downs bumps and potholes
but certainly you'll be living much
happier than helen
who is today of course cancelled and
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show you know
some people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin